>> WEBBER: Hi, good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Joel Webber. This is Ray Cromwell
and Stefan Haustein, my partners in crime
over here. And we're going to talk a little
bit, this afternoon, about HTML5. That seems
to be a common theme in this conference. And
specifically what you can do with HTML5 and
the Google Web Toolkit. A little setup work,
just remember that there's a live Wave going
on. There is also a moderator question and
answer there. And at the end of the talk,
we'll get questions from both moderator and
from the mics. So, we're going to talk about
three things today, we're going to show you
three things today, something for your eyes,
something for your ears and something for
your Id. In other words, we're going to blow
something up. You may have heard a little--a
thing or two about this. And specifically,
we're going to talk about what you can do
with Google Web Toolkit on top of HTML5. Obviously,
HTML5 is its own technology but there are
some specific advantages that GWT brings to
actually doing HTML5 work to take advantage
of these modern and bleeding-edge browsers.
So first of, I'm going to clear up a couple
of things about HTML5 itself. We have a formal
definition that is the things that are actually
in the spec called HTML5, you know, just best
practices for HTML interpretation, some new
elements, things like audio and video, so
forth and so on. Then we have the thing that
we actually are referring to most of the time
when we say it colloquially, which are--which
include things like canvas. Canvas may be
part of the spec, I forget. But other specs
like WebGL, WebSockets, all the stuff in CSS3,
lots of little ancillary specs and we've really
been referring to it more in a colloquial
sense as a whole in this conference because
we believe that really captures the essence
of what sort of coming in the next phase of
all these browsers that are busily updating
themselves right now. So, very briefly, you
may be asking yourself if you're a current
GWT user, "Where are all these great HTML5
features in GWT?" And the answer is most of
them are in extra libraries right now because
we spend a lot of time trying to make GWT
actually across browsers so that if you write
GWT code, it will actually compile and run
everywhere within reason. We haven't moved
these things into GWT proper for the most
part, but there are a lot of external--internal
and external open-source libraries for wrapping
features like WebGL and WebSockets and so
forth and so on. And we're going to try to
move these things into the core GWT over time
with appropriate measures to determine whether
they're supportive or not so that you, at
least, to know what browsers you're actually
going to be able to support. So first, WebGL,
so, all three of us are ex-graphics guys,
some game industry people. And when we saw
WebGL, we thought, "This is pretty cool. I
had no idea when I was working on this." It
turns out that there was someone at Mozilla
whose name I forgot now but, well, I will
thank at the end for starting this work, originally
called Canvas 3D. It's essentially OpenGL
ES 2.0. If you're a graphics geek, you know
what that means. It's the same OpenGL APIs
you see in Android and the iPhone, and they
have been made JavaScript friendly. So, things
that were sort of C-style APIs have been morphed
into more JavaScript-friendly APIs. The--I
guess, the work began at Mozilla, but it spread
quickly in the Safari and WebKit which--and
all three of them have--I mean, nearly--I
would say at this point, nearly production
grade implementations. And it's the thing
we all kind of hope it was coming when we
saw canvas.getcontext and it took an argument
that said 2D. The obvious implication of that
is at some point, we get 3D. It turned into
WebGL rather than 3D, but the idea is the
same. Little bit of a deep dive. Stefan's
going to tell you a lot more about the details
of the implementation. But, the WebGL, if
you're a graphics person, is kind of an interesting
beast because it's really a drastic simplification
of original GL libraries. Again, there won't
be a pop quiz on these details but the--it
really moves a lot of the work into shader
languages and that's actually the really core
thing that makes OpenGL--makes GL ES and therefore
WebGL special. And that's really, really great
for Web browsers because the JavaScript VMs
have gotten really fast, but they're not C-code.
C-code has gotten really fast, but they're
not specialized graphics processors. The more
you can move over to these specialized graphics
processors, the more really crazy heavyweight
stuff you can do that would just have been
completely intractable had you tried it in
JavaScript or often even in just raw C-code.
So, first, something for your eyes, I'm going
to have Ray talk about a little library he
built that does some things that I think you'll
find it fairly interesting. Again, take this
with--understand that these are sort of just
bleeding-edge demos. These are things--they're
not finished products or anything like that,
but their--there are attempts to really see
what we can do with these new features in
a fairly short period of time. So, I'm going
to pass it on to Ray now.
>> CROMWELL: Thanks, Joel. So as Joel talked
about, HTML5 has added a lot of new stuff:
WebSockets, new elements, new APIs. But some
of the most of important APIs that's added
has to do with media manipulation. So--I mean,
it's one thing to use a video tag to just
playback content, but it's another thing to
use it to actually edit video. And some of
the things that people used to do with flash,
because they can only be done with flash or
be done with a plug-in, can now be done with
HTML5. So what I've done is I've put together
a little demo to kind of show what's possible.
And the demo here basically is to try to recreate
Photoshop filters in the browser, but to make
them run really perform it. So what we want
to do is we want to make these filters work
on megapixel images, and not just some kind
of like small image you took with your cell
phone but, you know, four megapixels, eight
megapixels and so on. So, we want it to be--we
want it to be really fast. Secondly, we want
to provide it in a--as like a general purpose
library for GWT eventually where if you want
to build your own filters you just kind of
concatenate together a bunch of low-level
operations like scaling, convolutions, transformations,
and so on, and you can just make your own
sort of Photoshop. But more importantly, we
want to leverage native acceleration where
possible. So, if you've got a WebGL-enabled
browser, we'd like to actually use the hardware
to execute these operations. So this is a
sort of high-level overview of the architecture
that, as we've implemented. It's basically
a tree of filters. And each filter does something
and it passes it on to the next one. So for
example the source filter, all it does is
simply load the image from some resource like
a URL or off the disk and so on. And then
you can basically send that into various other
filters. One example would be like a ColorOP
would--could convert it to grayscale or sepia
tone it or something like that. Another one
would be a convolution filter. And convolution
filters are really powerful. Many, many, many
of the Photoshop filters use convolutions
like sharpening and things like that so you
can do that. And you can blend them together
so you have separate layers and you do like
Photoshop-like layers and blend them together
and just output them to display at the end.
So, one of the things you might be asking
is, "Well, what does GWT have to do with this,"
right? I mean, if it's JavaScript and WebGL
in a browser, you could probably just write
what I'm putting up here as the architecture
in JavaScript. And that's true, you could.
But what GWT buys you is two things. If you
saw my compiler talk yesterday, it's able
to optimize the JavaScript a lot more so some
of these really hot loops for processing pixels
will run a little bit faster. Secondly, it
allows us to target multiple platforms. So
that's okay too. But anyway, there's two implementations.
One of them is based off with just the Canvas
tag. And this new API where you're able to
get something called a CanvasPixelArray and
actually looked at the raw pixels of a JPEG
or a PNG that you're loading in. However,
this mode's probably not going to be as fast
as the hardware accelerated one. So for really
large images like eight megapixel, we might
have to like sort of crop it down and let
you only kind of work on a preview image.
And then, the second implementation is WebGL.
So if you've got a WebGL-enabled HTML5 browser,
we're hoping that it's going to run blisteringly
fast. So, here's an example of one of the
operations I'm going to show you, it's called
convolution. Now, what's a convolution? A
convolution is simply a weighted sum of nearby
pixels. So if you kind of think about you're
taking one pixel, and then taking the ones
that are right or next to it, and multiplying
those by some value like 0.5 or 0.3, and adding
them all together, and then using that as
the final output pixel. And the way this is
represented typically is by a matrix. So up
here is a 3x3 convolution filter. This is
actually the sharpen filter. So, if you're
using iPhoto or Photoshop and you say "Sharpen
this image," this is actually what it does.
And what it's doing there is it's saying,
"Look, take the current pixel you're operating
on and multiply it by five. Take the pixels
to the left of it and to the right of it and
above and below and multiply those by -1.
Add them all together and output them." And
you can make up your own convolution filters.
You can plug in whatever your numbers you
want to just sort of play around and creating
filters. But one important property is that
if all the numbers add up to one at the end,
it will preserve the overall brightness of
the image, so that's an important property
of convolutions. Some of the other convolutions
you might be familiar with, Gaussian Blur.
If you've seen drop shadows or glow effects,
that's how they do it. So, we have a pure
Java implementation written in GWT. And just
to sort of give you a taste of the amount
of processing that's going on in JavaScript,
for a 5x5 convolution--that's a 5x5 matrix--on
a one megapixel image, you're going to do
25 million multiplies adds, loads, and stores
times three because you've got to do it for
red, green, and blue, and sometimes for the
alpha channel. So that could be up to a hundred
million operations in JavaScript. And if your
image is, let's say, twice as wide, it's four
times as bad, so you can imagine it could
get slow pretty quickly. Now, the WebGL implementation
takes advantage of pixel shaders. So if you
got WebGL, what we do is we upload a shader
onto your graphics card and the actual code
executes on the chip itself. And if you're
interested in actually how this is really
done, there's a great article that NVIDIA
has in their online book called GPU Gems.
It's available at this link that will tell
you precisely how to implement these filters
on the hardware. But basically, it's just
really simple if you know anything about graphics.
You take the image that you want to process
and you bind it to a texture, then you just
render a rectangle that's of a certain size,
the size of the image, and you attach this
pixel shader to it. So every time it tries
to copy a pixel from the texture to the rectangles
that's drawing it, it applies your code. It
says, "Well, I need to write out a pixel,
so I'm going to execute this little time mini-program."
And then finally, you just kind of run this
in a loop if you want to apply a chain set
of filters. So, now, I'll show you a demo.
Okay. Hey, Joel, the back tick trick didn't
work.
>> WEBBER: Sorry.
>> CROMWELL: Okay, I'll just switch over.
Okay. So, here is an image of Notre Dame.
And what I do is--have--is I have a little
sort of scaffold up here around my library
and I'm going to do some Photoshop filters
on it. So
the first that I'm going to show is done in
JavaScript. So for example, I'm going to click
Gaussian, and I'm going to blur this image.
So I'm going to click this button once and
you can see it's kind of frozen, the browser,
and it took 1,600 milliseconds. That's like
1.6 seconds. I could click it again and keep,
making it blurrier and blurrier. Using a different
convolution, you could do edge detection.
Well let's--let me reset it. I combined the
blur with the edge detection. That didn't--okay,
hold on. Let me reload it. Okay. Let's do
an edge detection. There you go. So that ran--oh,
that's the WebGL. I'm sorry. That's why it's
so fast. Here's the edge detection in JavaScript,
672 milliseconds. So, there's another button
I can click here, which is WebGL, and that's
going to switch me over to hardware rendering
mode. And if I click--I'm going to reload
the browser, it's cached. So if I do it here,
you can see I can click this and I can just
keep clicking it as fast as I want, and it
just responds instantly. Like if I sharpen,
I can sharpen it up, I can emboss it, and
so on, grayscale filter. And likewise, if
I'm doing like a color space correction, it's
like real-time. So, if you're like editing
the exposure of a photo, you want it to be
like super real-time. You don't want this
like, wanted to take like half a second every
time you adjust. In fact, WebGL is so fast
that we can actually play a video. And, you
know, I can emboss Conan O'Brien in real-time,
or I can edge detect him, so. So, if you haven't
seen this, it's pretty funny. It's Vick and
Conan together. So, that's the gist of that
demo. Let me go back to my presentation. Yeah,
I keep forgetting where I am. Okay. So what
is--what I have shown you--what I've shown
you actually is a library written in GWT called
IMGwt for image processing for Google Web
Toolkit. And what it is has two implementations.
It's a pure Java implementation and a WebGL
implementation. Now, this is where it comes--the
question of why GWT come in, because you could
do this with just pure JavaScript. And the
reason is this, the pure Java implementation
can actually run in the Cloud. So if you wanted
to do some image processing in the server,
so upload it to the server, you could run
this inside of App Engine if you want it to,
it's pure Java. Likewise, you could even port
this to Android and just stick in the Android
graphics APIs on the bottom layer, and it
would work there too. But the front-end API
would be the same. And it's got a compact
DSL-like API so you just do something like
"imaging.load" a URL; ".convolve" an array
that has your kernel; and then ".to" and a
widget to actually poke it into. An important
fact, I've measured these WebGL filters up
to 1,700 times faster than JavaScript. So
if you want to edit really, really large images,
doing it in JavaScript or doing it with, like,
SVG filters is not going to fly you. WebGL
is the way to go. So, now something for your
ears; can I see a show of hands? How many
people in the audience have ever owned a Commodore
64? Wow, I didn't expect that. So if so, you're
going to--I think you might like this next
demo. So, I was--we were trying to think about
what kind of demos could we do that kind of
really freak you out. And I think this one's
pretty freaky. So what we did is we ported
a Commodore 64 emulator to JavaScript using
GWT. And the demo I'm going to show you is
not the formulator. This is just the sound
part. So what I've done is I've ported, essentially,
the Commodore 64 emulator just to run a SID
player for SID music. How many people know
about SID music? Okay. So what this is? Is
it's just--basically, it's a complete Commodore
64 emulator that only exists to playback SID
files. So, let me go there. Okay. So, I'll
briefly play--actually, this is not going
to be Commando because I don't have the rights
to it. It's a different song. But I'll click
the link, and it's going to load up, let it
play for a second. Okay, so enough with that.
So, Commodore 64 emulator in a browser. Let
me go back to my slides so I can tell you
what's special about it besides the fact that
Commodore 64 is cool. All right, hold on,
Joel, my--I want to kill that. I think it
was still playing.
>> WEBBER: Did you escape your way out.
>> CROMWELL: I probably did. All right, let
me--it's going to go back to--yeah, okay,
I'll just skip ahead. Okay. So, what did we
do here? This is the demonstration of HTML5
audio, but the current audio element can only
playback the static sound files that you've
got sitting on the Web somewhere. So, what
this actually demonstrates is the fact that
you can dynamically generate audio in the
browser, but there's kind of a couple tricks
you have to do. But the emulator, to do this,
has to actually run a cycle-accurate Commodore
64. That means like a million times a second.
It's got to be executing the processors opcode,
it's going to be fetching from simulated memories,
it's got to be updating all the I/O chips,
and actually for the sound chip in particular
to make it sound authentic to an original
Commodore 64, it actually emulates the hardware
analog circuitry that was on the backend of
the Commodore 64 so the capacitors and resistors
and all that kind of stuff to make it actually
sound completely accurate. So it, that take--it
takes a lot of processing power. And the browsers
are getting fast enough, they can finally
do this. So just to keep in mind, SID music
is not data, it's not like an MP3. It's not
a Codec. It's basically a code. So the way
you play the music is you have to run it.
And the way this demo works is, is at basically
44,000 times a second. It samples these virtual
I/O registers that are being emulated in a
browser and then collects them into a buffer.
And then what it does is it takes that buffer
and it encodes it as an audio/wave, a PCM
file and then base64 encodes it into a data
URI. And then finally, inserts an audio source
equals that URL, which is a long URL which
has the entire sound clip in it and it just
keeps doing that as the song is playing.
>> WEBBER: Yet somehow, it actually works.
>> CROMWELL: Amazingly, yeah. So, that's it
for audio and the browser. And if people are
interested in a deeper dive on this or how
to do other sort of audio tricks, you can
combine WebGL with audio processing, so you
can do all kinds of cool things like having
the hardware do echo and reverberation and
things like that. But, now, I'd like to bring
Joel up on the stage to give you what you
all have been waiting for which is blood and
guts.
>> WEBBER: I expect maybe you've already seen
this before but, so it won't be a real pop
in the demo but still fun to see. So, this
also goes back to the question of "why GWT?"
So, what we've done, okay, for those of you
who aren't aware of this, is to take the Quake
II game from 1997, which still looks remarkably
good for a '97 game, I must say. Taken a Java
port of it called Jake2 that someone wrote
a few years ago. They sort of transliterated
the code directly into Java for Java could
run this quite fast, which it actually does.
And we saw this right about the time that
WebGL started actually coming up with real
implementations, just started seeing a real
implementation in WebKit and Mozilla, the
Firefox. And we sat--and we've kind of scratching
our heads and thinking, "Well, could we really
port that? Would that work? No, there's no
way. There's no way it'll work." But, you
know, why not, right? It's more fun that working
on trying to optimize table rendering so,
I don't see why not, so let's give it a shot.
By the way, I wanted to make this a multiplayer
demo, but as you've seen from both keynotes,
wireless is incredibly unreliable. So, we're
just going to do a single player. Oops. Loading's
a little slow and I'll explain why later,
specifically. Ah, there we go.
>> Established communications. We're already
out.
>> Computer update.
>> WEBBER: Let's see if I can play it for
the track pad and survive. Notice that I put
it on easy for a reason. I hope you noticed
this is handling about 23 frames a second
on this laptop at 1024x758. Not as good as
we'd like it to be, but it's not too bad.
Ooh, I got that guy that was beautiful. Well,
you know why they put the barrels there, right.
They put them so you could blow things up.
So, you get the general idea. We've actually--this
is just a demo level. We've seen the full
game run quite well. Actually, if I go that
way, I'm going to get my [INDISTINCT] in a
big hurry. I've been there from experience,
so. And this is a very literal port. So, we're
talking about the direct code, all the logics
here, multiplayer works like a champ. There's
a guy hiding right there. I played this once
or twice. And there's somebody hiding, and
there he is. It doesn't like having perfect
[INDISTINCT] knowledge of the universe to--I
hope you get this. I mean, it's sort of like
Groundhog Day with guns. And can I make it
through here? All I really want is a shotgun.
There we go. Okay, I'll stop boring you with
this any minute now, but I'm having fun, so.
>> CROMWELL: You know you can't stop playing.
>> WEBBER: What time is it? Thirty, okay,
we have plenty of time; 37 minutes. Hey, this
is my last talk ran over--ran under by 20
minutes so, I'm not going through that again.
Okay, let's see if we can make it through
to the fun part, the guys with the big machine
guns. Think about the--I mean, think about
the fact we're talking about a browser right
here. There we go, that's a much better weapon.
I mean this is a--this is a browser you're
looking at here. I mean imagine how cool it
would be if I could just send you a link,
you click on it, and you're in a multiplayer
game with me. I mean, this is the--this is--this
is a--oh, crap--this is a proof of concept.
But, you know, when you think about--there's
a guy behind me. Oh, no head. That's not good.
Here we go. All right so, anyway, okay, I'm
a--I really am going to stop now. All right,
I'm going to kill that guy and then I'm going
to stop. All right, all right. Oh, demo time.
That was demo time, okay. So, before I let--Stefan's
going to take an incredibly deep dive into
all the details. He did a lot of the graphics
work in this and there was a fair amount of
it. But the question of why--again, why GWT?
What is really valuable about having done
this through Java as opposed to just writing
this, you know, on JavaScript? Now, I might
not be able to prove this statement, but I
strongly believe that with the complexity
of that code base, I think, what was it? A
hundred thousand...?
>> HAUSTEIN: A hundred thousand lines code.
>> WEBBER: Have you ever take, thought about
100K logs for the IBMers out there. That's
a really complex code base. It's convoluted.
It's a good code by '90s era game standard.
It's a very clean code. But that's by '90s
era game standards. It took an enormous amount
of tooling to get through this process. And
again, I'm going to let Stefan go into details.
But the tooling that we provided, the tooling
that was provided by Eclipse, we primarily
used Eclipse. Or IntelliJ would be fine as
well. Any tool that can revive lots of cross-referencing,
lots of "Find me all the places where this
piece of code is used," "Find me all the places
where, you know, [INDISTINCT] with this piece
of code is used." Tell me when I made a mistake.
Show me a red squiggly in the browser when
I had just screwed something up. It was a
complicated enough porting process had we
just, you know, without having to worry about
those kinds of problems. Without the tools,
I don't--I honestly don't think we would have
ever completed it because we're really talking
about 20% time, really sort of -5% time project,
the stuff that happens between 10 pm and midnight
at home. So, that's the reason this is a GWT
related, I would argue. And I have more to
say about that later. But first, let me let
Stefan go into the excruciating technical
details of what actually happened to make
this go.
>> HAUSTEIN: Thank you, Joel. Yeah, so when
trying to do this port, we faced a set of
problems. And the first problem was rendering.
So the Rendering API used in the Quake, original
Quake source code, Lightweight J--Lightweight
Java OpenGL is based on OpenGL 1.X, and it
uses a Java nio buffers for data transfer.
But WebGL is based on OpenGL ES 2.0 and you
don't have any fixed function pipeline there
and it uses its own WebGL arrays and buffers.
And arrays and buffers are distinct, and you
don't have this distinction in pure Java.
And of course, we didn't have any development
mode support for WebGL in GWT. Then, we have
problems with resource loading because there
is no file system in the browser, and the
Quake code loads everything from the file
system. And if we want to use XHRs for loading
resources, they are asynchronous. So they
don't really fit into the control flow of
the existing code. And local storage is synchronous,
but it has a very limited capacity. Then,
for networking, Quake uses UDP, but there
is no UDP support in any browser in JavaScript.
And some Java APIs to Quake code base are--is
using are missing in GWT. And, of course,
we have not any, didn't have any idea if it
would be fast enough. Okay. So the first part
is the renderer port. So, our first idea was
to just do our drop-in LWJGL emulation, and
just to emulate the missing GL 1.X fixed function
pipeline. But the problem is that a pure drop-in
wouldn't take advantage--wouldn't be able
to take advantage of the DOM-based image loading
capabilities of WebGL and handling image data
at a pixel level were transferred to WebGL
in JavaScript seemed too expensive. And, finally,
we needed slightly different signatures to
support WebGL buffers. I'll come back to this
later. So, instead of a pure drop-in replacement
for LWJGL, we added an intermediate abstraction
layer that is close to our original API and
still uses nio buffers. And the nio buffers,
we emulate using WebGL arrays. And a nice
property of the GWT development mode is that
the nio buffer emulation falls back to pure
Java nio in development mode and that enabled
us to create a WireframeRenderer that we could
use to the backend development mode result
needing WebGL. So the whole structure of their--our
implementation is that we have an abstract
GLAdapter at the top and/or we have an LWJGL
adapter that still runs the original code
base, so we
still can run it in Java and pure Java on
the desktop. And then our abstract GL 2.0
Adapter does all their fixed function pipeline
stuff. And that's used by the WireframeRenderer
and the WebGLAdapter. And that's how their
wireframe mode looks like. A trivial translation
from GL 1.X to WebGL is to turn all the calls
that set vector data into sequences of glBindBuffer(),
or glBufferData() and then glVertexAttribPointer().
To make this faster, we changed the code to
make sure that static data, like level geometry,
static lightmap coordinates, and stuff like
that, is only copied to a buffer once and
then reused. And in the code, we did this
by assigning a unique ID to reused buffers
so we can identify and skip the copy step
for WebGL, but still run the original code
in pure Java. We did some other rendering
improvements for WebGL, basically to reduce
the number of GL codes--GL calls. So we ported
GL_DrawAliasFrame in mesh to--from DrawElements
to DrawArrays and the reuse part of the GL
setup when rendering strings of text. The
next problem was our resource loading, porting
resource loading to asynchronous I/O for textures
that was quite straightforward. We just deferred
the corresponding GL calls to the onload event.
And in the meantime, we use a holodeck texture
that looks like this. You have seen this by
loading the game I think. And that was quite
straightforward and had little impact on the
control flow of the game. And the sizes of
all images which are needed in building the
models are sent to the client in JSON as part
of index.html. Porting the code for loading
models and maps was a bit more difficult.
As I said earlier, Quake assumes asynchronous
access to resources so it required a significant
amount of refactoring. The main trick there
was to skip frames while resource loading
is in progress. So for networking, we replaced
UDP with WebSockets. And with the renderer,
async IO, and networking implemented, we were
able to run multiplayer games. So, ironically,
multiplayer support was the easy part because
we didn't need to port any of the server logic.
However, we wanted to get the demo mode running,
so we would have something that we could use
as some kind of benchmark that we could reproduce
and that would like output some kind of frame
rate and then you see how good your browser
or computer performs at--with WebGL. And after
making sure that all of their additional causes
that were needed for this would compile, nothing
worked for us. So, we kind of knew that there
must be an error somewhere in our changes
but diff show that we have like changes everywhere.
And that made it kind of hard to find the
bugs. So, instead of trying to fully understand
what was going wrong, we just tried to review
some differences and that means we reverted
all unnecessary changes in the code base such
as import clean ups, package changes and formatting
changes. And we also replace other changes
in the code. All changes where we could do
emulations. We did so. So we added there a
simple file system simulation based on local
storage for saving preferences and games.
Before that, we were using a local storage
directly for this stuff. We ported some additional
parts of java.util and we pushed down the
networking changes from our pretty high-level
where we're using the JSON messages to our
lower level of the NET class and the code
base that's more at a byte-level. So, with
those changes, we got the differences down
to about 60 from 200. And we also were able
to reduce the amount of changes in the remaining
classes. This didn't really provide much insight
into the nature of the bugs we had in our
code before, but it made them go away. And
that's where I would like hand back to Joel.
>> WEBBER: Thank you. That was a pretty crazy
process. Thankfully, Stefan is smarter than
I am. He was able to make it all work. I'm
the one who made all those diffs that he had
to revert. Then I came just hacking and slashing
through it and then thinking I'm sure it'll
work out fine, or I'm sure I can debug it,
well, maybe not. But, so--okay, so we saw
this and I mentioned a minute ago it was running
20, I use 22, 23 frames a seconds on this
laptop. This laptop is significantly faster
than the machine you probably own in 1997
and this frame rates are actually quite a
bit lower. So this really bags a few questions,
I mean one--and I'm--okay, to be fair, in
my Linux desktop at home which is rather beefy,
it runs at about 60 frames a second which
is kind of nice. But still, it should be running
at about 500 frames a second on that machine.
I'm making up the number, but a lot faster.
So this bagged a few questions, like I said.
One, is it the code? What can we do to the
code to make it faster? Two, what could we
do to the--well, the code and the compiler,
that's because there is a compiler involved.
What can we do to the browser to make it either
just directly faster or change the APIs in
such a way that we could make things run faster
by using the APIs more intelligently or creating
better APIs. And three, what does this tells
about the inherent limits of actually porting--of
actually running JavaScript code. Inherent
or near inherent, or at one assumes that VA
performance will eventually tap out to some
maximum or some asymptote. And so, you know,
what's possible in JavaScript and what's,
you know, what would be--what would require
you to switch over to something like native
client? You know, as far as the--as far as
the code itself is concerned, you know, this
is two levels of porting across two different
languages effectively. I mean, at two different--certainly,
two different target platforms. And the code
got pretty crufty in the process. There's
a lot things being done in code that would
be better pushed off to the vertex shaders
as well. So there's a lot of things that,
you know, there were no vertex shaders in
this code that was written. So things like,
I mentioned mesh animation here. Mesh animation
is done. Quake II did not use bone deformation.
It used just key frame point clouds and did
linear interpolation between them. That's
in straight up Java code and JavaScript ultimately,
and that's really slow because it's essentially
DSP-style, floating point DSP-style work.
I mean, down in the language, it was very
much not designed for it. So we could move
that over into the vertex shader and probably
get a lot more performance out of that, a
whole lot more, I'm sure. And we've seen that
as a common hotspot because each one of those,
even the little rotating things are still
running this deformation code. And certainly
all the characters are. So there are a few
other things like that, but those are essential
the bigger hotspots when your running in the
game. GWT compiler optimizations; one of the
goals also was--well, at least for me, personally--was
discovered things we could do in the compiler
that we're not currently doing as well we
could. This is a big complex, apps. There's
a lot of opportunities to learn from it. We
discovered a couple of particular things that
were nasty for this code that are a little
unusual. One, it initializes lots of little
bit arrays. Usually for, you know, major [INDISTINCT].
And that is unfortunately--that unfortunately
incurs some overhead in the GWT compiler output
right now that we aim to eliminate. Just some
minor semantic fix-up between Java and JavaScript
arrays, but we can get rid of that. I'm going
to make Ray do that because he's a better
compiler guy than me. Lazy Static initializers
are also a serious problem. So static initialization
when you hit a class for the first time, we
do that lazily because that's the Java Semantics.
And because there are so many static methods
in this code, you're triggering the static
initializers everywhere. We--I've been pushing
to eliminate those for a long time even if
we do break the Java Semantics to make it
a dash X atomization or something. That would
make a pretty big difference and, you know,
at a complete guess, I would guess, we could
probably get 20% or so or at least more speed
out of those--out of those kind of changes,
maybe more than that but I may be wrong about
that mesh animation stuff. And if we were
to completely rewrite the code rather than
just porting what was there, there are probably
a lot of other things where the code--they're
doing things that made sense and see that
are probably, you know, had become awkward
through translation. So that puts us in the--let's
say, that puts us in the realm of, you know,
40% faster. There, you're talking about something
that's tractable like that's, you could build
a real game that way. You're not going to
build Crisis 27 this way but, you know, the
far crime which everyone is the engine, which
everyone is the game. You're not going to
be building that in the browser anytime soon
using JavaScript. And probably you're not
going to want to port your C game to JavaScript
anyway if you have a game written in C, you're
probably going to want to use native client
for that. It's a perfectly sensible thing
to do. We just wanted to prove the balance
of where it could get to. So, then it comes
to questions of "What do I do to make the
browser itself faster?" Now the JavaScript
engine could get faster but there's probably
some inherent limits there. I don't know what
those limits are. I should probably ask the
V8 guys what they think the limits are. But
it's going to have--there's going to be some
limits on that. One thing we really did find
though, because this is really probably one
of the first big things built on top of WebGL
is certainly that I'm aware of. And we really
wanted to push on the APIs before they were
solidified so that we could push back if there
are things that needed to change. What we
really discovered was in--I mentioned earlier
that loading was really slow. I mean that
load--that map should have loaded it. It was
completely cached. It should have loaded in
less than a second or two. I mean there's
a lot of stuff in there. You know, there's
two megs of binary data or so for the level
itself plus the mesh animations and so forth
take up some space. Parsing that binary data
in JavaScript is excruciatingly slow. If you've
ever--if you want to understand how slow it
is, go try to write parse float in JavaScript
from bits. It's exactly as bad as you might
imagined and we hit that thousands and thousands
and thousands and thousands of times in the
course of loading a level. Which begs the
question, "Why are we even parsing floats
in JavaScript? Why can't we just pass that
data directly through the WebGL?" And WebGL
has these TypedArray classes, WebGL, ArrayWebGL,
FloatArray, et cetera for this purpose, for
loading data directly to the card efficiently.
The problem is the gap's not covered between
XML HTTP request, WebSockets, and the WebGL
layer. They don't speak the same language.
So you end up having to parse all those data
out in a slow way in JavaScript or Strings,
Strings and then ultimately bit fields, and
then repackage it in a form that WebGL wants.
So it turns out that the guys at Mozilla and
Khronos Group who manages WebGL's spec, and
on the Chrome team. We're already thinking
about this problem. We got together and we
said, "Look if you were to make the other
APIs in the browser speak the same language,
we could make processing binary data in the
browser a lot faster." Some experiments yielded
results are probably to at least to, if not,
more, or is the magnitude faster. That also
would have made Ray's life a lot easier with
the audio example. You've, I'm sure some of
you cringed when he said "I packed it all
into it. I PCM encoded it and then packed
it all into a data URI, base64 encoded it
and shoved it into the URL field," like that's
just wrong. I mean it's really cool that it
works, but it's just wrong. So--but that's
another perfect example of a place where if
you just made all these APIs speak the same
language, you can have huge optimizations
that have nothing to do with making your code
run faster and everything to do with not running
code at all. So, you know--that--there are
a few other things we discovered as well.
In particular that there are some inefficient
frame buffer handling in Chrome right now
that the team already knows about it and is
working on. So, if you shrink that window
down, the frame rate goes up pretty fast which
is kind of surprising, given that it was not
pushing the card very hard. So they--they
are certainly aware of that. They're going
to work on that as well. But they already
knew about it and they're working on it. So,
the point, again, is let's see what we can
do with HTML5, colloquial definition of HTML5
as it exist in modern browsers right now.
And that to recap--I mean to reiterate what
we actually showed there where that was--that
demo was WebSockets, WebGL, audio, where I
showed the video tag earlier.
>> Local storage.
>> WEBBER: Local storage, right, local storage
per settings and preferences, things like
that. And the Canvas itself obviously mixed
2D and 3D rendering. Anything else? I think
that was it?
>> HAUSTEIN: HTML5 would probably.
>> WEBBER: Yeah, as Ray said, if it's an HTML5,
we'd probably use it. And that was kind of
the point. And, you know, again, this is not
for necessarily--we're not suggesting that
everyone should go porting their C games to
JavaScript but I think this is a pretty compelling
demo. What you can actually get done now,
completely ignoring the native stack. I mean,
I think that is pretty impressive. And this--doing
these kinds of demos will help us continue
to get the APIs right so that we have proofs
of concept before the API solidify, and we
can really build the browser into a real platform.
So, and I think this is probably--you're probably
aware of this but the code is all--it's all
an open source. It's all on a Google code
projects so you're welcome to download it
and try it yourself. Obviously, we don't own
Quake, so we can't just put up our own servers
and let everyone play, but it's really easy.
There's a couple of scripts. Download it and
try it yourself and get LAN multiplayer death
matches going like it's 1997. So, a few thanks
also before I forget, ED Software for being
a really, really awesome about open sourcing
almost everything they do after it gets only
slightly long in a tooth, Bytonic Software
for doing the actual Jake2port of Quake and
proving that it could actually be really fast
in Java, and the Khronos Group for maintaining
and actually pushing the spec forward. Also
Vladimir, I would simply say Vladimir. If
anyone has any idea how to pronounce his last
name? Please let me know. Thank you very much
for getting this whole thing started, and
somebody--the guy at Mozilla who really kicked
off this whole process. And, Ray wants a special
shoutout for [INDISTINCT] of Covert BitOps
who actually provided the license Commodore
64 music. We really wanted to play the Commando
theme but, you know, we can't even find who
owns it anymore, so.
>> I think [INDISTINCT] Commodore 64 [INDISTINCT]
greets.
>> WEBBER: Greets to, yes, you're right. That
would be the hacker term, "greets to" [INDISTINCT],
so thank you very much for providing that,
and thank you all for sitting through this,
we appreciate it. With any luck, feel free
to come to the microphones if you have questions,
and I'm going to try and cover the ones in
the [INDISTINCT} the moderator link as well.
We'll do a little of both.
>> Hey. Well...
>> WEBBER: Wow.
>> Is that image library posted somewhere?
>> WEBBER: I'm sorry?
>> The image from the first example. The image
library, is that GWT library posted somewhere?
>> WEBBER: Oh, the image. Did you put that
up on the...
>> CROMWELL: No, it's not available yet because
it's kind of in a wonky state. But as soon
as it is in a nice state with some documentation,
I will be releasing it. I'll probably announce
it on GWT users or GWT contributors list.
>> Okay, thanks.
>> WEBBER: Okay, yeah, and as soon as we,
as soon as Ray gets a little post eye of sleep,
he'll probably do that. And I'm going to go
back and forth if it's okay between there
and the--wow, that's a lot of percent 20s.
We will be promoting the use of with GWT with
WebGL as a gain development platform. I think
I've addressed that. You know, this is an
experiment more than it is an actual proposal
for the way you should be doing things but
it's something to learn from. And, yeah?
>> SO, I've certainly never, I've certainly
never have ported any, you know, graphics,
games, or anything like that. But I've created
a couple libraries, Java libraries that are
meant to be targeted both by javac and by
the GWT compiler.
>> WEBBER: Right.
>> Rather than having two sets of code, I've
sort of, you know, gone through the strife
of trying to make, you know, one little--one
package that can sort of be used in either
situation.
>> WEBBER: Right.
>> And I've done that a few times now and
I've started to see some of the abstractions
that can be made--Anyway, so, I'm just wondering
if, you know, the GWT team at Google has started
to notice similar abstractions and if there's
any effort or dream to come up with a set
of standards for making libraries that are
meant to be compiled by either javac, or the
GWT compiler.
>> WEBBER: Right, so I mean, I wouldn't say
as such in an overarching effort but there
are particular cases where, for example, we've
run into problems with like collections being
inefficient when like maps and sets, in particular,
being hyper inefficient when--well, barely
inefficient when translated to JavaScript.
And we're trying to, for example, look at
replacing some of those collections or with
lighter weight versions, for example, where
it would--that would work well on a server
but also are built with the constraints of
JavaScript in mind. If there are other cases
that you're hitting--I know there are some
cases where we're simply missing like the
strain constructor that takes a byte array.
Mostly because it's a giant paint implemented
in JavaScript, and we had, we ran into a bunch
of those as well. But if there are specific
cases that you've hit and if you're noticing
a pattern of cases you've hit where you had
to do extra work to make the code work on
both server and the client, and assuming it
wasn't things like, you know, thread that's
just not going to work. We probably should
actually be accumulating that knowledge somewhere.
So, if you could bring it up on the contributor
list, I'd really appreciate that actually.
It'd be really helpful.
>> CROMWELL: I think it's fair to say also
that we've kind of been thinking a lot about
code that runs in multiple context lately
in sort of ways that we can tweak the super
source mechanism to sort of generalize it
more and...
>> WEBBER: Right.
>> CROMWELL: I think that's--maybe in the
future we'll have better answer for sort of
a hacky way that's done today.
>> WEBBER: Right, right, and that can actually
really go along with those answering questions
about, not just server and client but also
say GWT client and Android client. Yeah, so
you can share code there as well. From here?
>> Cross-browser compatibility has always
kind of been a paramount goal of Web development
that I felt. What do you tell somebody with
a bad GPU, or a non-open GL 2.0 capable GPU
that can do these GLSL and VBO things that
you guys are putting on to a browser. The
same thing video game vendors say, you're
screwed or what?
>> WEBBER: I would say--and feel free to butt
in if you guy have other thoughts. I mean
there's a serious problem, right, especially
on Windows platforms where you tend have a
pretty good DirectX driver and a really terrible
OpenGL driver--does anyone remember the name
of the project that we open sourced recently
to.
>> The angle, the angle project.
>> WEBBER: What was it?
>> The angle project, A-N-G-L-E? [INDISTINCT].
>> WEBBER: Oh, that's it, that's it, exactly.
Yeah, but--so that's one opportunity, someone's
just really needed to sit down and write a
good OpenGL on DirectX abstraction. Probably
comes in some overhead, but it's a lot less
overhead to not running at all. And, you know,
and this is sort of forward-looking, all right?
I mean, this is--these are things that--this
will be serious problems. People on bad GPUs
or people that only support, you know, the
simplest kinds of shaders and things like
that. So we view this is really forward looking
in that sense.
>> Is there any type of CPU fallback mechanism
in WebGL? Or it would just be so unbearably
slow, it's not worth it?
>> WEBBER: It would probably be slow. So slow
it wouldn't be worth the trouble.
>> CROMWELL: I think for the...
>> WEBBER: But it's not directly true. That--there
are some, but it would have to be at the driver
level.
>> CROMWELL: I think maybe what Khronos was
getting at is because OpenGL was such an enormously
large library. They kind of maybe went a little
bit too far in stripping it down. But the
idea was basically if they remove all of the
old fix function cruft, they can make the
surface area they [INDISTINCT] a lot smaller.
So for like iPhones and mobile devices, it
could be more compact. And the people who
are partnered with Khronos, basically--or
essentially, voting on that spec and their
saying, "Yeah," Apple is saying, "Yes, we
will put a GPU capable of doing OpenGL ES."
And probably Android came to saying, "Yes,
we will do that." So that's probably how that,
it arrived at that state where it's like,
if you got a DirectX 8 card on a Windows machine,
you're probably out of luck. But we do have
a Canvas Renderer so if you want to go with
flat shading, you can still play it. You just
won't get textures.
>> WEBBER: Right, one of the thing on that
front is that if you look at where OpenGL
is going, WebGL, OpenGL, you know, all the
new Android device--all the Android devices,
all the iPhones, I believe the Palms as well
are supporting in baseline of GL ES 1.5 or
2.0 whichever it is. So, that actually could--if
that forces GPU manufacturers across the board
to get into a mode where pretty much any device
that you get. I mean we're talking, you know,
my little phone has a pretty good--you know,
pretty solid driver on it. That can provide
a pretty stable baseline. And that's a pretty,
that's a good enough baseline to do anything
that we can do for example. I mean, it's pretty
much a similar level of functionality so.
It's a little farther off in the future, I
think, before that long tail of old GPUs goes
away. But once we can get to that point, we
have a pretty stable baseline for writing
code across a wide range of devices, okay.
Sir?
>> Sort of three implementation questions.
The first one Web servers is UTF-8 bound.
Did you guys use BSON, B-S-O-N, for encoding?
>> WEBBER: Oh, you don't want to know what
we use. I'm just kidding. It's--we--okay,
I'll not to drive too deep on this. We have
seven minutes, but, very briefly we cheated
like crazy and use the custom encoding which
cause it through every byte as a separate
entity. There's a few, I found a few libraries
that use this trick. You have to fix up anything
that falls above HEX, FF, something or other--or
something like those weird fix up code you
have to do. And this is precisely the kind
of stuff that we basically--the precise of
the reason that we wanted to move binary support
directly into XHR and WebSocket and things
like that. I mean strings are just not always
the right--lowest common denominator. In fact,
it was--even if you take something like JSON--we
tried base64 encoding. That was even worse.
Base64 encoding was really, really slow, comparatively
speaking. We're talking about two megs, you
know, plus base64 overhead. That just takes
forever to decode. And we've tried, we even
tried JSON encoding. The thing is, you're
parsing an entire programming language when
you do that and it is, you know, you think
of it as really fast in a browser because
it's so much faster than anything you could
write by hand. But it was, in my experiment,
it was 250 times slower. Almost precisely
than the equivalent just raw packed buffers
passing on the straight through. We kind of
hacked up Chrome a little bit to do that.
And so that's, again, that's the reason to
work around that, to do that. String encodings
are the only option you have right now though.
You're absolutely correct about that.
>> And the second question is, resource loading
and mesh loading you mentioned are using JSON.
Did you guys look into doing, say, loading
a texture, binding it on a Canvas, and then
pulling it in as--rendering it with a vertex
shader like a hide map fields sort of thing?
>> WEBBER: Sorry, loading texture, I miss
that.
>> Loading a texture, and then using a vertex
shader to adjust the mesh?
>> WEBBER: Oh, you mean to--you mean for adjusting
the textures themselves, the gamma correction,
and that sort of thing?
>> A faster way to load the resource, the
mesh resource.
>> WEBBER: Oh, oh, oh, oh.
>> CROMWELL: He means like decoding them,
I think, isn't it?
>> WEBBER: I'm not sure, that might have work.
It would be--you'd be paying for a buffer
copy backs from the, over the card. That probably
is still faster than what we did. Would you
explore that?
>> CROMWELL: Yeah.
>> WEBBER: That would, that might actually
work. It's kind of a freakish hack...
>> CROMWELL: Yeah, our first...
>> WEBBER: ...but it will be really cool if
it worked.
>> CROMWELL: Our first hack [INDISTINCT] was
using like CanvasPixelArray and we were, because
it was Quake code where it's doing like its
processing images before it uploads into the--and
puts them in the image and its like doing
gamma correction.
>> WEBBER: Right.
>> CROMWELL: We have the light maps get all
processed up and...
>> WEBBER: We ultimately dropped most of that,
right?
>> CROMWELL: Yeah, we dropped most of it.
>> WEBBER: The light maps are still processed
by hand, I think, but anyway. I'll come back
to that, but sorry. Question?
>> When will GWT support a file API?
>> WEBBER: Support?
>> File API.
>> WEBBER: Oh, file API? I think there is--so
there's often a little misconception about
what GWT sort of supports and doesn't? As
I mentioned in the beginning, there are things
that we have baked into the actual core jars
that again here to four have always tried--we've
always tried to make a cross browser. But
there are a lot of open source projects. And
in fact some of the--if you look up on going
Google code, the regular project hosting site,
search for GWT and HTML5, you'll find two
or three libraries. They seem to be converging.
Most of them are written by external people,
but we're just eventually going to talk to
them about bringing their code in that abstracts,
you know, WebSockets, file API, local storage,
WebGL, Canvas, et cetera. So--and they're
solid. They seem to be from what I've seen.
So, don't hesitate to look there for other
sources of APIs. We'll--again, we'll try to
bring those in as fast as we can, but it definitely
it shouldn't stop you from using those.
>> Yes.
>> WEBBER: Let's see, more GWT, [INDISTINCT]
support Canvas, I think that's pretty clear.
Unrelated.
>> CROMWELL: Size question.
>> WEBBER: Oh, that's--okay, so this question
is about white paper describing the whole
process. I guess we have a slide deck now.
Stefan went into quite some detail on that.
And SVG, [INDISTINCT], et cetera. Again, look
for third party libraries. People--you know,
we're fairly a small team and there are a
lot of people out there doing a lot of good
work faster than we can ever get around to
it. So definitely look for open source projects
when it comes to these things. And, what will
happen to flash? Those are good questions.
I have no idea. Hopefully, it will continue
to do very well as it's moving into Android
and so forth.
>> CROMWELL: On the size question, I think
the compiled and gzip Quake binary, the Quake
binary is like, I think it's like a 100K or
something.
>> WEBBER: Gzip maybe.
>> CROMWELL: Yeah, gzip. It's like a 100K.
So it's actually, it's not too large.
>> WEBBER: Right.
>> CROMWELL: It's the--all of the RSS are
actually the large part of it.
>> WEBBER: Right. Anyone else? [INDISTINCT].
Nope. Okay. Well, thanks again, everybody.
I appreciate your time.
>> HAUSTEIN: Thank you.
>> WEBBER: And, okay.